this is what the cost of living crisis
looks like
a choice between feeding your kids
or heating your home
a choice dawn is faced with day in and
day out
the more you're worrying about how am i
going to pay this
um the worse you actually feel
and then announcement like this comes
along and you you feel even worse
and you're worrying even more and
it's a bit of a nightmare
and today that nightmare continued the
chancellor's statement didn't include
anything to benefit those on universal
credit dawn says the 300 pounds a year
she'll save from their national
insurance changes is non-existent
we're paying that out already
or we're going to be from the locks of
it with the amount that fuel and food
and everything's going up and it just
feels like no matter what we're trying
it's
we're not getting anywhere we're not
and we're actually getting worse and
worse
off
thankfully it was a warm spring day at
berry market a welcome start difference
from life at home in the cold a life
irene and lila are used to
they don't put me central eastern on
i've been about i think it was about 25
quid for this big blanket thing and i
put that on at night just sit under it
you know
do you think the politicians down in
london do you think they understand the
situation
no
no they'll be wrong
the politicians listen but not enough
he's thankful to see the price of fuel
drop
but with it at a record high he's
worried it's still too much the concern
is that people come from fire and why to
bury market it's going to cost them
together with fuel prices it's going to
cost them all together and then they've
got to pay for your parking and
etc etc it just goes on and on
this is a crisis that will inevitably
hurt the poorest the most
but the suffering will be widespread
millions of households across the
country are bracing themselves to feel
the pain when it deepens next month
in zaman rasheed sky news berry